[Música]
eu sou anad gostaria de apresentar a
vocês meu grande amigo também grande
músico artista gaúcho aqui está ele em
pessoa charme pessoa max garcia
[Aplausos]
então a gente vai fazer a primeira
música em homenagem à nossa maravilhosa
de jamila ribeiro que está na frança
promovendo seus livros tendo o livro
editado agora em francês
o nosso negritude está chegando longe
então essa música é uma música francesa
mas é um black music em francês um
artista negro francês chamado bem no
show
[Música]
[Risadas]
júnior bateu montasse é o lado de cá faz
um som do burro g anjo no wako tio era
[Música]
fácil e rodolfo bem como foi meu show
bem leves motos graças on their tom papa
a sirf como ryan mulher
[Música]
é o eja tubos bom eu to
vem comigo aqui ou assim quando eu já
faço do bongi
a juno vacante é adicional roubei como
planejam vem enquanto na seção dias não
tava
se fomos um riso é bom
[Música]
já to pass manda
a ju tombos voa do to
[Música]
obrigada
essa música se chama é fake homem barato
música que a joana mencionou que tem
como protagonista
eu e como protagonista 2 mas não pode
ser 2 pela manhã
sandro goiano mais nova de uma estrela e
como protagonistas várias mulheres ajuda
joana está presente também faltou ao
enem na próxima
tá bom
essa música sandra lhe descobriu eu
nunca tinha visto o potencial político
dessa música que fala sobre os homens
fake e eu acho que ela representa um
pouco que a gente pensa sobre esse tal
de patriarcado né então é fake homem
barato
o refrão vou convidar você para cantar
comigo
[Música]
existe um homem de verdade
o moleque só emita a embalagem é bonito
só que o produto de camelô nunca
funciona direito parece perfeito que não
durou
nunca funciona direito parece perfeito
que não durou
todo mundo já conhece já está mais
falado de samba de breque
a verdade sempre aparece você não é um
homem com o nec nec funk é frio deus que
parasse garrafa de jack
efe é frio você não é homem você é
moleque é frio e whisky barata em
garrafa de jack eu falei que eu peguei a
fio
você não me gostei de amanhã é que
[Música]
existe um homem de verdade
a mulher que o pirata até a desculpa é
para a pena pra
perdeu a credibilidade é homem
mediterrânea não dá garantia não tem
validade é homem que teria não dá
garantia não tem validade
é que o homem de verdade pode ser mais
novo do que aparenta não se trata de
idade tem moleque coroa com mais 40
o moleque é sempre igual nunca foi
original eu falei que é fake é filme
elvis quebarato garrafa de jack é feito
efe wells que para brigar fazer dieta
efe efe ojl você não é um homem você é
moleque é feito é fio é o esqui barata
em garrafa de jack eu falei que é feito
é frio
você não é um homem bateu a mãe diz que
é homem de verdade mas não faz o seu
papel já de longe que fãs
desses que nem a cópia é fiel
esse é o que wdk perseus início lá não é
bom
antes que desaparece na minha filha se
ligando pro co efe o embaraço cigarro
mas isso é você não é único termo leque
efe é frio eu te barata em garrafa de
jack o moleque é pq a frio
quero ver quero me quero nem quero ir
[Música]
eu acho que barato em garrafa de jack
você não é homem você é moleque e whisky
barato garrafa de jack eu falei você não
é um homem você é moleque
[Música]
você não é homem você moleque e whisky
barato em garrafa de jack eu falei que é
fake a frio
[Aplausos]
obrigada a fazer a última música
vocês já conhecem com certeza não
conhecem vão conhecer agora vão se
apaixonar
acho que representa tudo o que a gente
precisa pensar sobre a nossa cultura
brasileira
[Música]
cordel não poder pisar mas na vinheta
quando as minhas pernas não poderem
aguentar levar meu corpo junto com meus
andar
[Música]
é
eu vou ficar
no meio do povo espiando a mangueira
ganhando mais um carnaval
antes de me despedir deixa sambista mais
novo
[Música]
não deixe o samba morrer não deixa o
samba acabar um novo foi feito de samba
de samba pra gente sambar
não deixe o samba morrer
não deixe o samba acabar de samba pra
gente samba mas quando quando eu não
puder milhar mais na venda
quando as minhas pernas não puderem
aguenta levava meu corpo junto com meu
samba
o meu anel de barro uma entrega há quem
mereça usar eu vou ficar
o uísque em escola perdendo bem
eis um carnaval
antes de me despedir
dei só uma pista mais o meu pit
no final
antes difícil fingir deixa o sambista
mais novo o meu feed do samba pra gente
salvar
[Música]
a gente não deixa o samba
a gente pede um beijo foi feito de
sangue
[Música]
o google possa cada vez mais ocupar
espaços como esse que no ano que vem e
se essa platéia esteja mais preta do que
está hoje obrigada pelo convite é uma
honra estar aqui cantando na frente de
sandra ali na frente do ine
obrigada de samba é uma honra cantando o
samba também pra gente
samba
[Aplausos]